[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of Avengers phase 4 to talk about
we got more details about the Eternals
movie Kevin Feige even did an interview
talking about some specific aspects of
it billing it as the secret history of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe taking
place at least a million years ago
although the entire movie might not take
place in 1 million BC we might actually
meet some characters in present day that
are eternals that have been secretly
living among us this whole time so we
got to break it down there's a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comments on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this there's so much stuff here
so we'll just do this top 10 style
starting with number 10 the movie is
supposed to enter production September
2019 which is relatively soon we didn't
know when they were actually gonna make
this Kevin Feige said that it was on the
schedule but he didn't say when it was
on the schedule September 2019 implies
that they plan on releasing it sometime
maybe late 2020 maybe they'll push it a
little bit later than that if things
take longer during the development
process but typically the really weird
movies that they're trying out that
they're not totally certain how big
they'll do at the box office like Doctor
Strange or the first guardians of the
galaxy film get released towards the end
of the year like August November
timeline so a pretty safe bet that
they're gonna release Eternals towards
the end of the year whether it be 2020
or the year after that nine we've
already found out that the writers that
were working on the project say they're
more inspired by it the original Jack
Kirby 1970s comic book as opposed to the
more recent ones but from what they say
about the villains and the casting
notice breakdowns it sounds like they
might also borrow a couple things from
the more modern Eternals comics there
haven't been that many they're really
only four volumes and if you actually
try to hunt down those Eternals comics
online they're not on Marvel unlimited
so already pretty hard to find and
they're not on comiXology which are two
of the only places to get legit digital
comics so you actually have to have the
physical copies or just hunt down a scan
if you actually want to read some of
these stories
that's how obscure they are but they
sort of serve as an origin point for the
MCU they do say that the story will
involve connections to modern-day
pre-established characters they're
talking about the Eternals and the
eternal story invoking a lot of
characters that are alive or were alive
in present day because some of the big
ones you'll notice on my list here have
died
or we think that they've died so
starting with number seven most notably
Thanos of Titan Thanos descends from the
Eternals even though he was born on the
planet Titan Thanos his grandfather is
one of the original
eternals so some of them left planet
Earth
they eventually landed on Titan they
became the society that Thanos talks
about when he had that scene explaining
how they fell and it was beautiful
Titan was like most planets 20 mouths
not enough to go around and when we
faced extinction I offered a solution
genocide but random his passion is fair
to rich and poor alike they called me a
madman and what I predicted came demands
keep in mind that the Eternals are
millions of years old they're called
eternal for a reason because they're
functionally immortal so Thanos is
extremely long-lived genetically he
carries the deviant gene so he looks
like the deviance but he really has
eternal DNA in him so that's why he's so
powerful naturally even without the
Infinity Gauntlet know the really
important scene there's ego the Living
Planet talking about his origins he is a
celestial the Celestials or at least the
first host of Celestials are the ones
that created the Eternals when he talks
about not remembering how he came into
being there are actually ways that the
Eternals and the Celestials can get sick
can die can suffer from diseases they
just have to be very big cosmic diseases
because he's billions of years old the
Eternals millions of years old
Celestials billions of years old five
there's the elders of the universe I'm
hoping that they tie them to the eternal
storyline because as the name implies
elders of the universe there's this
casual line that the Grandmaster slips
in during Thor Ragnarok where he says
time moves differently on Sekar if I
were anywhere else I would be millions
of years old so it's just a fun way of
winking at that and the fact that there
are all these Jack Kirby Eternals
designs all over his palace and his
guards are dressed like some of the
Celestials all really subtle things in
present day that they can pay off during
the Eternals movie because you remember
this a car is sort of like the
universe's trash dump they're a bunch of
wormholes that exit they're the devil's
anus pretty easy way to explain how all
that celestial tech can find its way
getting dumped there for we have Odin
and his father bore the line of
Asgardian all fathers there's this line
during Thor Ragnarok where Thor is
talking to Serdar and says didn't my
father kill you about a million years
ago so it was a fun way of winking at
the fact that Odin is also super old in
the MCU they sort of get into the idea
of the Odin sleep during the first Thor
movie but they don't totally explain how
it works or how old he really is to get
into a little bit of MCU ancient history
during that pre-credit sequence and Thor
the dark world where Odin is explaining
how his father defeated the Dark Elves
so if you keep in mind that Odin is
almost a million years old then you have
to imagine that this is happening even
before then so maybe around the time
that the Eternals are being created by
the Celestials three
bagi has teased that it's sort of like
the secret history of the MCU mostly
talking about the earth-based characters
in explaining the true origin for
super-powered people mutants if you want
to call them that enhanced individuals
that have changed on a biological level
Marvel Comics just did a really big
Avenger story bringing those characters
into modern-day continuity involving a
lot of retcons to what the Celestials
did and the reason why they created the
Eternals they use it as part of this
larger plot between Celestials and dark
Celestials in this war they were
fighting and they also retcon the origin
of the Infinity stones in this really
big way
but I would expect them to simplify that
quite a bit because even if you haven't
read it it sounds kind of complicated so
they might just omit the idea of dark
Celestials altogether but to the actual
casting breakdowns we have Cersei Icarus
Gilgamesh Macari Alicia's Tina xerus it
even lists starfox who's actually Thanos
his brother so it'll be interesting to
see how they incorporate him because
technically he wasn't one of the
original Eternals so we'll just wait to
get some more information about how
they're gonna use that character but if
you wanted Starbucks it seems like he's
gonna show up during this Eternals movie
the main villain is supposed to be drew
league he's a recurring Eternals villain
regardless of which era you've read
which volume one two three or four he
typically shows up as an antagonist and
it winds up being a kind of Game of
Thrones situation whereby his father is
one of the original leaders of the
Eternals he wants to bend the other
Eternals to his will so that he can rule
them all you have the good Eternals who
are led by his nephew Icarus so when
you're thinking about main characters
really it's like druid main villain
Icarus main hero in number one Kevin
Feige just did a recent interview where
he talked about them again referring to
them and a very guardians of the galaxy
scenario he says your reaction about not
being familiar with the Eternals is
perfect because most people are like who
the hell are the Eternals I have no idea
what's going on he went on to say
because most people weren't familiar
with the guardians of the galaxy and
believe it or not there were people that
were not familiar with the Avengers or
Iron Man so for us talking about Marvel
collectively it's finding great stories
whether people have heard of them or not
in bringing them to the big screen in as
amazing a way as we can so he said
things are gonna get weird there
definitely gonna get weird with the
Eternals but think of it as being like
Game of Thrones in the Marvel Universe
with Greek mythology but let me know in
the comments if Star Fox is listed on
the casting descriptions and they're
doing Stannis's brother how do you think
they're also going to reference fan OHS
during the movie if he would be either
very young or not having been born yet
when a lot of the events of this movie
are happening there's a whole bunch of
other Marvel videos that I'm working on
but leave your requests in the comments
below I'll try to post everything as
soon as possible congratulations Ian
Mills you're the giveaway winner from my
last big video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for that
infinity war alternate ending and click
here for that brand new Spider Man
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]